[Music]
hello and welcome the new leader of the
uk conservative party will be announced
in the next few hours opinion poll
suggests that foreign secretary liz
truss is the front-runner
trust and former chancellor rishi sunak
have been campaigning for months to lead
the governing conservatives the winner
will replace boris johnson who will
submit his resignation to the queen on
tuesday
now the new prime minister will inherit
a raft of challenges including energy
shortages
and rising inflation let's go straight
to our correspondent jonah hull who is
live for us in london look it's been a
difficult contest for the party in
what's been a very difficult time for
the country give us a bit of background
and also how do you expect things are
going to unfold today
well it has been an almost two-month uh
political transition high stakes high
drama from the old prime minister to the
new and we are very nearly there a
result expected in the next couple of
hours it began of course on july the 7th
with the resignation of boris johnson
off the back of the so-called party gate
affair illegal gatherings in downing
street and other government buildings
during periods of lockdown that set in
train a leadership contest featuring
candidates from every faction of a
deeply divided party eventually whittled
down to a race between rishi sunak a
former chancellor and liz trust the
foreign secretary she is the favorite to
win to have secured a majority of votes
among an estimated 160 000 conservative
party members who are making this choice
a tiny sliver of the wider electorate of
course their decision will be made known
in about three or four hours time now as
to who the next leader of the
conservative party will be
to go on of course on tuesday to succeed
boris johnson as prime minister after
meeting the queen and whoever that
person is trusts or indeed sunak will
inherit the reigns not just of a divided
party that has deposed three uh of its
its previous three leaders in the past
six years but also of course much more
importantly taking the reins of a
country in the throes of a series of
deep deep crises from skyrocketing
household energy prices to eye-watering
levels of inflation a cost of living
crisis in the context of an economy
thought to be already in recession
faltering public services and of course
the wider umbrella background a war
on europe's borders with russia and
ukraine it is a pretty formidable to-do
list
so what are we expecting from the new pm
once he or she gets into office
well as i said whoever that person is
will have one priority and a very very
immediate one and that is to get to
grips with these multiple domestic
problems inflation that is predicted to
hit 20 by the end of the year energy
prices that by january next year could
be triple what they were a year ago
strikes across public sectors are
faltering health service one in eight
britons now on nhs
waiting lists
and all the while this cost of living
crisis spiraling winter is coming
heating will become more expensive
eating will become more expensive many
families may have to choose between them
it is a grim contest rishi sunak has
been pretty clear-eyed about the extent
of it calling it a genuine emergency
promising help to those who need it most
this trust has promised it a package of
help within a week of taking office if
she does so and in her acceptance speech
if it happens she said that hard
decisions will be required some of them
will be unpopular but she's promised
honesty about what is required and that
issue honesty of course something uh
that the still current prime minister
boris johnson has frequently with uh
been charged with not being
indeed uh joe nahal therefore us in
london will be speaking to jonah
throughout the course of the morning we
are expecting that decision at 11 30 gmt
we will of course bring it to you here
on al jazeera
now kenya's supreme court is due to
deliver its